hallo wir sind in berlin der stadt in
der der döner erfunden wurde und wir
zeigen euch jetzt wie man einen döner
bestellt
[Musik]
hallo ich hätte gerne zwei halloumi und
gemüse die türen bei grün halloumi
dankeschön so bitte ich hätte gerne ein
bisschen scharf und sonst was ist der
rest klose und für gute saison ja dann
nämlich knoblauch
[Musik]
[Applaus]
hallo einen vegetarischen halloumi
bürger im brot bitte gerne und 1 1 1 1
ok danke
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich hätte gerne ein büro und ein kebab
und der deckung kommt ohne käse und ohne
zwiebeln bitte ohne käse und ohne
zwiebeln
[Musik]
jetzt wird meiner vorbereitet ein
klassischer dünner
[Musik]
zwiebel und knoblauch soße und ein
bisschen schaffen alles jetzt esse ich
meine bühne
[Musik]
die seele kann
manuel warum bist du so gerne dünner
döner macht schöner toll und schlank
[Musik]
manuel wie kommt es dass der döner
erfunden wurde
ein türkisches gericht oder der döner
wie es ihn in berlin gibt wurde 1972 von
türkischen immigranten in berlin
erfunden
in der türkei aus in der türkei gab es
vorher einfach nur das kebab fleisch und
brot separat und in berlin wurde zum
ersten mal das fleisch in das brot getan
zusammen mit gemüse
einen döner bitte einen döner mit
scharfer soße bitte einen dürren bitte
einen falafel bitte einmal halloumi
bitte einen vegetarischen döner bitte
ich hätte gerne zwei döner zum mitnehmen
einen döner teller bitte beim döner
alles drauf ohne zwiebeln bitte ich habe
noch was vor alles darauf mit scharfer
soße bitte ohne käse bitte mitnehmen
oder hier essen zum hier essen zum
mitnehmen bitte
ich hätte noch gerne einen iran dazu
eine cola bitte bitte nehmen sie sich
einfach die getränke das war unsere
episode zum thema döner wenn er in
berlin seid solltet ihr unbedingt mal
einen döner probieren wie war deiner
manuel richtig lecker und bei dir sie
meine aufweist gut dann geht man hier
hinunter städten döner
wir bedanken uns fürs zuschauen und wenn
ihr lust habt jetzt noch weiter deutsch
zu lernen neue vokabeln zu lernen und
videos zu sehen dann probiert doch mal
unsere apps siedlung aus da könnt ihr
nicht noch mehr lernen und hier seht ihr
wie die app aussieht probiert es mal aus
wir freuen uns wenn
das ausprobiert und uns einen kommentar
dann hast danke dass ihr dabei war sehr
gerne danke für den döner karli und bis
zum nächsten episode da gehen wir pizza
essen und dann bürger
[Musik]